[Música]
momento de salud aquí en directo a
América de France 24 Ya está lista con
nosotros más Romero sala bienvenida
Gracias Rosa hoy vamos a hablar de Sudán
un país que lleva dos a meses en
enfrentamientos abiertos entre el
ejército regular y los paramilitares y
la salud es una de las principales
afectadas de este conflicto Sí Rosa es
algo que sucede en la mayoría de
situaciones de conflicto no al final la
salud es una de las primeras cosas que
se ve resentida y también aprovechar
para hacer esa reflexión de que
normalmente en estas situaciones también
son las organizaciones precisamente de
salud las encargadas de dar los partes
de víctimas por ejemplo no de cuantos
fallecidos y heridos han habido porque
son la primera línea de defensa al final
de precisamente la vida en un momento en
el que eso se convierte en algo
prescindible o nimio desde la agencia
reuters retransmitían un poco el parte
que está dando la Cruz Roja regional
africana sobre la situación en el
terreno escuchemos
los hospitales con los que podemos
hablar nos dicen que hay cortes totales
de elec tricidad no hay comida ni para
los trabajadores ni pacientes según el
Ministerio de salud y la OMS hablamos de
que solo queda un 20% de hospitales en
jartum
hemos escuchado historias muy tristes
sobre pacientes muriendo porque es
imposible recibir la atención sanitaria
necesaria a veces porque falta personal
porque los doctores son incapaces de
llegar hasta los pacientes que se supone
que tienen que tratar o por la falta de
material y asistencia
sabemos Rosa que las condiciones son
especialmente críticas también en toda
la zona de darfur y especialmente en la
ciudad de
lgella donde además en estas zonas de
conflicto ya son 60 hospitales los que
han tenido que cerrar y los que
funcionan funcionan con cortes de luz o
sin agua es decir una situación
verdaderamente dramática y más le pido
una algo Que supongo que parte de
nuestra audiencia se plantea también
Cuáles son las cifras de esta crisis
humanitaria Sí pues por supuesto es
difícil recolectar una información
precisa en unos momentos de estos de
tanta inestabilidad pero
que según las cifras de la OMS 4,7
millones de personas en Sudán en este
momento necesitan algún tipo de
asistencia humanitaria y son más de
100.000 los menores de 5 años que están
en riesgo de sufrir desnutrición severa
esto nos muestra también que habrá
consecuencias Más allá de las de los
enfrentamientos o de las heridas digamos
que nacen de uno conflicto armado sino
que estos problemas de desnutrición de
problemas de atención a la salud se
cronifican también con el tiempo y harán
que un país que ya dependía un poco de
la ayuda humanitaria sea todavía más
dependiente Incluso si el conflicto
termina pronto no uno de los problemas
que más se habla también es esta falta
de ayuda para las enfermedades crónicas
por ejemplo para los pacientes de
diálisis hay unos 8.000 personas en
Sudán se calcula que necesitan diálisis
por enfermedades renales por
enfermedades de los riñones y es un
tratamiento sin el cual no se puede
sobrevivir y ya está pasando de hecho
había reportes del sindicato de médicos
holaneses de 12 por faltas de
electricidad en los hospitales donde los
estaban tratando de día diálisis no y lo
mismo sucede al final con tratamientos
contra el cáncer con la lucha contra el
VIH podemos hacer una lista infinita de
todas estas dolencias que se ven
afectadas e interrumpidas también por
culpa de un conflicto que hace que todo
esto pues al final deje de ser
importante O prioritario sí que pase un
segundo plano no finalmente
mar cambiamos de tema venimos aquí a
América Latina porque Bueno hay
revelaciones sobre la salud mental de
los emprendedores en la región Qué pasa
Exactamente Bueno es un informe
publicado por el banco interamericano de
desarrollo que nos han pasado además
nuestros compañeros de economía para que
lo revisemos y básicamente dice que la
Salud Mental es uno de los principales
factores que influyense un
emprendimiento funciona o no la Salud
Mental por supuesto de los emprendedores
que lo que lo impulsan vamos a revisar
algunas cifras generales en este sentido
decían que después de haber hecho
encuestas en toda América 6 de cada 10
emprendedores sufrían niveles moderados
de lo que llamamos burnout no de este
desgaste del trabajo del agotamiento
profesional y dos de cada diez un nivel
Severo es decir en total son ocho de
cada 10 que sufren algún tipo de
desgaste profesional o de este burnout y
después también son tres de cada 10 los
que mostraron algún síntoma de malestar
psicológico que era uno en término
paraguas para hablar de relaciones de
tener relaciones positivas con otros de
poder tomar decisiones con tranquilidad
de estar bien y tranquilo y aceptándose
digamos a uno mismo es decir una un
panorama en el que vemos pues que sí que
este agotamiento y este impacto que
tiene el trabajo sobre la Salud Mental
es bien fuerte Mary para traducirlo y
para nuestra audiencia en español lo
podríamos Traducir Quizás por estar
quemado colapsado en el trabajo algo así
no Exacto estar quemado yo creo que
sería la definición perfecta quizás un
poco demasiado coloquial pero
efectivamente si él no no dar más estar
desilusionado estar angustiado no poder
concentrarse esos son algunos de los
síntomas y antes de pasar a unas cifras
que sé que usted también nos tiene
preparadas le pregunto exactamente Qué
entendemos por emprendimiento en América
Latina no porque puede ir desde alguien
que tiene una gran empresa alguien que
digamos vende comida con un carro en la
calle de forma informal Quizás sí por
supuesto o sea en América Latina yo creo
que particularmente la idea del
emprendimiento es muy elástica se
entiende por cualquier persona no que
decide montar su propio negocio y en ese
sentido ser responsable también de sus
propios ingresos y eso precisamente era
una de las cosas que mostraban como una
de las cosas más estresantes o que
generaban más angustia más sentimiento
de responsabilidad también de culpa
Precisamente en estos personas
emprendedoras en este caso Igualmente le
informé se centraban los emprendedores
de alto impacto es decir que en este
sentido no contaríamos quizás personas
que aquí se usa Este término tan
laxamente no como
que vende en la calle que a veces de
hecho en Bogotá mismo no se considera
como un emprendimiento sino personas que
realmente montan un negocio de una
envergadura un poco más alta en este
sentido en estos términos estamos
hablando
tienen uno solo la responsabilidad de
económica de sí mismos y de su familia
sino también de trabajadores a su cuenta
no exactamente sí un factor que bueno
también sobre todo depende de la
moralidad de las personas puede suponer
más o menos estrés mar le pido Ahora sí
algunas cifras que ilustren este
panorama Sí también tanto para
emprendedores como en general veíamos en
el informe algunas cifras de cómo estas
personas quieren buscan lidiar no al
final con estos síntomas de desgaste con
estos problemas de Salud Mental y
básicamente vemos que la mayoría de
ellos acudían a cambios en el estilo de
vida hablamos por ejemplo de hacer
ejercicio de caminar de dormir mejor de
tomar menos alcohol o tomar menos café
entre las cosas esto lo hacía el 84% de
las personas encuestadas luego también
había personas que buscan acudir a lo
que han llamado conexión Social es decir
pasar tiempo con la familia pasar tiempo
con los seres queridos amigos pareja
también acudir a lo que llamaron también
como un término paraguas prácticas de
espiritualidad o religiosidad por
ejemplo meditar sería una de las cosas
que están incluidas ahí y también por
supuesto un tercio un poquito más de un
tercio de las personas también acudían
un poquito menos perdón a lo que es el
trabajo
psicoterapéutico con especialistas no ir
a terapia básicamente para tratar de
lidiar con todas estas cosas pero
realmente después de ver no estas cifras
yo creo que lo que reflejan realmente
también es a lo que nos falta No lo que
hace falta a las personas en el mundo
laboral seas emprendedor o no no todas
esas cosas que nos hacen sentir mejor y
también poner la pregunta de Quiénes
tienen el tiempo o quienes tienen la
disponibilidad de hacer todas estas
cosas no por ejemplo
no tener que atender o cuidar a otras
personas de la familia no pasar dos
horas al día en un transporte público
para acudir a tu puesto de trabajo y
tener que volver no tener que no sé Ahí
entran a jugar condiciones de trabajo no
de tener trabajos que nos permitan al
final una vida digna para poder cuidar
de nuestro bienestar mental emocional y
como eso también revierte luego
positivamente en el trabajo no lo
hacemos probablemente después con más
ganas o con más energía entonces bueno
seamos emprendedores o no ver a qué
acuden estas personas cuando se sienten
mal o abrumados en el trabajo Yo creo
que es una muestra También de todo lo
que necesitamos todos al final claro
Omar porque al final Pues hay empresas
que ponen en práctica No cada vez está
más de moda el tener espacios de
relajación en el trabajo de meditación
Pero hay factores que continúan
estresando como son horarios sueldos
etcétera no Sí por supuesto y que al
final muchas veces el incluir dentro del
trabajo
estas medidas a pesar de que por
supuesto deben ser es mucho mejor que no
tenerlas se ha visto de hecho que
revierte mejor no tener tanto trabajo
tantas horas laborales si no poder
decidir personalmente cada uno Cómo usar
el tiempo libre para estar uno mejor que
al final nosotros somos los que mejor
sabemos que necesitamos por supuesto más
Muchísimas gracias por esta Crónica y
este análisis Gracias a ti Rosa